Stephen twitch boss danced his way into
the hearts of so many and those hearts
are forever broken with his tragic
passing welcome to Entertainment Tonight
it still doesn't seem real no it just
does not seem real twitch's death
resulting in an outpouring of love and
reigniting conversations about mental
health this as family and friends try to
make sense of life without him
[Music]
such a painful reminder that you never
ever know what people are going through
listen I think people have to just stop
assuming that when you see people on
television that they're okay especially
with the dancing I mean dancing is such
a symbol of freedom and happiness and
joy I like the rest of the world I'm
shocked by the death of Stephen boss
twitch he was obviously suffering with
mental health issues and it's a big big
big problem in the United States
E.T has learned twitch's autopsy
occurred yesterday the medical
examiner's office has confirmed that the
40 year old died from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to the Head his body was
discovered here at this Encino Motel
less than a mile from where twitch lived
with his wife Allison and their three
children that's where his family has
come together to grieve both twitch's
mom and Allison's were spotted yesterday
outside the home twitch's former co-star
Channing Tatum shared his heartbreak
posting this pic from the set of Magic
Mike double XL and writing I have no
words there aren't any my head or heart
cannot understand this Channing told me
he was in awe of twitch's moves unreal
when he dances like I my mouth is just
on the floor like the whole time he's
gonna he's gonna blow people's mind in
this movie he's like Neo inside the
Matrix inside the song it's it's pretty
extraordinary this morning Ellen posted
a tribute clip from the second to last
day of her show something that I'll
always remember is that you gave me a
place
or I could just be myself you know what
I mean and speaking of Ellen Rosie
O'Donnell was candid shutting down false
there's no like Hollywood cabal that's
out killing people and why the hell
would they
what could he possibly have seen or
known at The Ellen Show
what that she was not nice to her staff
everyone knows that
also getting real Tyler Perry who opened
up about his own past suicide attempts
I'm a living witness you can make it
through it I'm so glad that my attempts
didn't work
rest in peace
[Music]